في رايي هذه السنه ستكون سنه حاسمه
بالنسبه للصراع والواضح ان روسيا بدات
تنتصر في هذا الصراع بشكل نهائي لانه كيف
لم تستطع
ان يعني ان تحقق اي نجاح عسكري ولكن لابد
ان ان ان ان ينتهي ان تنتهي ان ينتهي هذا
هذا الصراع سينتهي طبعا بانتصار روسيا في
في اعتقادي وفي نفس الوقت
ا الواضح تماما انه
ال السلطه النزيه في كف كيف ترفض كل
الحوار مع روسيا ترفض كل ال المحاولات
لايجاد حل سلمي ولذلك مكتوب على هذا
الصراع ان يستمر الى الانتصار النهائي ل
مسكو في الحقيقه نحن لا نريد شيئا لا نريد
اولا لا نريد اراضي لدينا اراضي كثيره لا
نريد ان مثلا ان نحتل اراضي معينه او ان
نسيطر على على ارض اوكرانيه ابدا
بالعكس الشيء الوحيد
الذي نريده من الولايات المتحده لان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هي التي
ورا كل الجهود التي تبذلها كيف وقياده
الزيه فيها مع الاسف الكبير ولكن نحن لا
نريد اي شيء كما قلت وما نريده من امريكان
ممكن ان نقول
يعني ان ان يتركونا لحالنا ان لا
يعقلوا جهودنا
لتامين الامن القومي
الروسي في راي ليس هناك اي تشابه يعني بين
ما تفعله اسرائيل اسرائيل دوله محتله
روسيا ليست دوله محتله وكن انها بالفعل
داخل الاراضي
الاكرانين ردا على تلك الحرب التي شنته
اوكرانيا ضد سكان الروس العايشين في
دونباس
لنترك القرم على على جنب لان القرم دائم
كانت جزءا من من روسيا
و هذه الفتره القصيره التي كانت جزءا من
اوكرانيا كان انضمام كان ضمها في لقرب في
اوكرانيا شيئا غير شرعي
و والامر لا يناقش حتى يعني بالنسبه لدون
باس في دونباس اثناء فتره ثماني سنوات
كانت هناك ملاحقات وقتل و
منع
حقوق يعني
بدائيه اساسيه لسكان الروس في هذه
المنطقه دنباس بشكل
عام تستمر وروسيا انتظرت انتظرت ان تكون
هناك ان يكون هناك ان تنجح يعني مسك
اتفاقيات مينسك وان تكون هناك
محادثات مع لها مضمون حقيقي وتفاهم
مع
الغرب ما نسميه بالغرب الجماعي
حول بناء نظام امن اقليمي في هذه المنطقه
ولكن كل هذه الجهود لروسيا والصبر الذي
كانت سياسه روسيا مبنيه
عليه يعني مكتوب عليها بالفشل الكامل لذلك
روسيا
كانت ملتزمه بالدفاع عن عن السكان الروس
دونباس
والاعتراف بهم
ك دوله
مستقله